hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at 8:00
p.m. or a glass and a half makes you a
better mom so pour yourself a glass
let's talk about stuff but today first
let's talk about while we're rough but
first here's what I'm drinking tonight I
don't know if you've noticed but I'm
dressed up because we have a very
special guest today there is a wonderful
gentleman here to teach us a little bit
about wine so let's welcome Christopher
Webb our fancy wine man hello my dear
my name is Chris Webb and I am a
sommelier at a restaurant in Malibu
essentially what I do is help guests
find the wine that they are going to
enjoy good day with a sommelier I feel
like you're used to
pairing wines with pretty fancy food
steak lobster caviar I have two kids I
don't really eat that is there any way
that we could do a couple pairings with
some of the foods that I typically eat
yeah you know I brought some wines here
we can I like you all right he said I
brought some wine okay so first I feel
like you're supposed to drink wine with
cheese so I brought some cheese I raided
my son's a lunch box
ah so the first lesson of pairing wines
with food in general is if it grows
together it goes together oh there you
go oh so like the home to mozzarella
cheese and Italy is compañía so any
company of red will do the same a little
bit more more just a little just a
squirt all right so first step little
swirl right oxidate s-- the wine so that
you can get all the wonderful aromas
I smell red wine for sure mmm what
there you go I'm just trying to be fancy
mmm what the heck are you doing why
would you ever spit out wine well
because if you don't spit it out you're
never gonna make it through the entire
tasting we don't waste wine in this
house okay okay
ie baby puffs a lot for lunch what what
our baby puffs this honestly they don't
really taste like much is there anything
that I could have that would add some
flavor to this my choice for this one
would be Australian Chardonnay new world
cherry which is United States South
Africa Australia those sort of places
wait are we learning history now -
mm-hmm
I think it kind of works hmm actually
like that yup when my kids aren't around
is when I like in Doyle my treats and my
wine so is there a wine that will go
with ice cream yes one of the main
things you want to keep in mind when
you're pairing wine with dessert is that
it always has to be as sweet or more
sweet than the dessert you're having
I've some ice cream sandwiches okay
this is the easiest dessert to sneak if
you have kids okay because even just
like shove it in your shirt and walk
into the bathroom with it I didn't put
these on my shirt don't worry okay this
is a dessert wine it's a Moscato d'Asti
it's not very expensive it's it's a good
value and compared with just about any
dessert cheers Cheers Hey all right
right oh my god right some of the
flavors and and aromas that I got is
like honeysuckle white peaches kind of
reminds me oh thank you so before we go
to the next one do you mind
like I love that we're being fancy and
dressing fancy but my stomach like
starts to pooch a lot do you mind if I
change into some sweats
no okay you can take off your jacket too
if you want to be more comfortable I'll
be right back
okay step totally not hitting on you by
the way I'm married I'm literally just
changing into something more comfortable
so as a mom a lot of the time your meal
is going to consist of whatever is left
on your kids plate so I'll eat pizza
crust from my kids plate but a lot of
the times doesn't have a lot of flavors
is there a wine that's going to bring
out the flavor of the pizza crust yes so
this is lambrusco not a lot of people
know about it it's actually slightly
sparkling it's very food friendly you
can go with just about anything so
here's my son he's clean he doesn't have
me cooties
cheers Cheers are you grossed out by the
beads across uh no um it's he stopped
eating his boogers like six months ago
it's cool last sometimes I live about 15
minutes to myself to drink my glass of
wine what's the kind of wine that's
gonna go down the fastest well not that
I would recommend a chugging wine or
drinking you don't have to but if I
guess if I was gonna choose something
that would be easy to drink my go-to
would probably be rose a rose a all-day
Rose a all day there you go I feel like
this is a sign because Rose day is my
favorite wine and he just said it's the
most drinkable should we try a chav uh
and gah oh that's a bad idea
that's all I got for today I feel like I
learned a lot so special thanks to my
fancy guest Chris we're best friends no
more wine friends so if you don't mind
topping me off with couple extra cents
sure there's not a lot left I don't
think we can do this again we gotta do
this every week till next time I'm
Hannah your friendly neighborhood why
mom just gonna enjoy a couple of cents
my
- forget a burp like stuck right sure
nothing brewing up or down
what camper I've never birthed a man
Taylor what yeah
Judas part everybody for not girls